we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P
we got a great voicemail of support
we already talked earlier about all of
the insane things happening Sean Hannity
Donald Trump Jr Candice Owen sending the
right wing mob against me we talked
about what's going on with advertisers
some advertisers sticking with us some
advertisers bailing etc etc
here's just a single message and I got a
ton of these a single message of support
from a viewer
David my name is Steve and I'm calling
just to tell you to hang in there be
encouraged
uh you're gonna come out on top of this
and I will support you in any way that I
can thank you it listened to you for a
long time
um
I've never had any problem what I've
heard you say
uh I think you're pretty right on pretty
sharp and I get a kick out of you
sometimes okay thank you David we need
you we need you don't be discouraged
thank you I can't tell you how much I
appreciate that a powerful message of
support against the hate mob so where do
we stand right now the antagonistic
messages have started to slow down to
some degree instead of a message once a
second it's now like every 15 seconds
now that doesn't sound I know it doesn't
sound that great
it's like David that that's good every
15 seconds it is better than what it was
and we will see where we are by the time
Monday lands I told you we lost a couple
advertisers I I don't know where we're
going to land but I I hope that
uh this caller is is exactly correct we
have such a great bonus show for you
today
a rift in the Republican Party
has been exposed as senators are warning
Kevin McCarthy against this Iraq vote
that is being discussed we're going to
discuss what's going on who might vote
which way and what Republican senators
are up to the FDA in the United States
has approved the over-the-counter sale
of Narcan which is an overdose reversal
drug this is widely seen as a great
thing while some are concerned that it
will
encourage overdosing because hey you can
just grab over-the-counter Narcan and
have it with you we will talk about both
sides of the discussion and Adidas or
Adidas as some of our friends pronounce
it has retracted their opposition to the
black lives matter three stripe design
what is this about what's the back story
what's the controversy I will tell you
all about it on today's bonus show
two great ways to access the bonus show
first and foremost sign up at
joinpakman.com oh the bonus show where
you want to make money they're
themselves as bad sir yes sir sign up at
joinpackman.com you can use the coupon
code cancel cancel that's all one word
cancel cancel meaning cancel the
cancelers trying to cancel us right now
second option you make a pledge on
patreon of at least five bucks a month
you can find that at patreon.com slash
davidpackman show we will see you on the
bonus show and I will be back tomorrow
with the Friday show